[Music]
in this section we're going to take a
look at Amazon DynamoDB Amazon DynamoDB
is a fast flexible no SQL database
service for all applications that need
consistent single-digit millisecond
latency at any scale so basically it's a
fully managed no SQL database that's
suitable for document and key value
store models it's perfect for mobile web
gaming and tech etc let us take a look
at some of the benefits of DynamoDB
firstly it's always stored on SSD
storage so you get great disk rooper
it's also spread across three
geographically distinct data centers so
you get high availability built in it's
fast and flexible and it's suited for
read heavy applications and it's worth
remembering that because you might see
question saying I have a read intensive
application with a database what should
I use and dynamodb would be the answer
dynamodb offers two different read
consistency types the first is
eventually consistent reads which is the
default and then this strongly
consistent reads so what does this mean
well when you write something to your
DynamoDB the changes have to be
replicated to the three geographically
distinct data centers on which DynamoDB
is being stored and obviously this is an
instant I mean it takes a couple of
seconds or so or less but it takes some
time so you can choose your read
consistency depending on whether you
want users to be guaranteed to have the
correct data or whether on occasions
when they run a query they might not get
the latest up-to-date version eventually
consistent reads which is the default
means that consistency is usually
reached within one seconds and repeating
a read after a short time should return
the correct data and it gives the best
read performance but there is the danger
of something called dirty reads which is
where you might request a read and you
might not get the latest up-to-date data
if it's essential that your application
gets the latest incorrect data then
you can enable strongly consistent reads
and this guarantees that all rights have
committed prior to the read taking place
so it could result in a delay to your
results being returned dynamodb is
charged using something called
provisioned throughput capacity when you
create a DynamoDB table you define the
capacity that you want to reserve for
reads and writes for write throughput as
a charge per hour for every ten units of
write capacity and this equates to
36,000 writes per hour for read
throughput
there's a charge per hour for every 50
units of read capacity and this equates
to 180,000 strongly consistent reads or
360,000 eventually consistent reads what
this shows is that DynamoDB can be
expensive for writes but cheap for reads
Spritle application has lots of reads
little writes and wants to be scalable
then you should be looking at dynamo DB
rather than RDS there's also a storage
cost per gigabyte for the amount of data
you use with dynamodb and here's a very
brief real-life case study duolingo the
online language learning site uses
DynamoDB to store 31 billion items for
their online learning site and they
deliver lessons in 80 different
languages and their application hits
24,000 read units per second and thirdly
300 write units per second so you can
see this is a very read heavy
application and is perfect for dynamodb
in this demonstration we're going to
take a very quick look at dynamo dB
you
so we go to the database section and
we'll find DynamoDB which is the manage
no SQL database provided by AWS so I'll
click on that
we're taken to the dashboard I have no
dynamodb tables so we need to create a
new table and we need to give it a name
so let's call this simply learn
underscore users that's going to be the
name of our table we have to give it a
key so a primary key so I'm going to put
in lastname
so that's going to be the primary key
for this particular table and that's
going to be a string now down here we
have table settings so we can use the
default settings and it says no
secondary indexes is provision capacity
is set to five reads and five rights and
has basically arms of 80 percent upper
thresholds so if an alarm if one of your
read or write capacities is greater than
80 percent of what you've set then
you'll get an alert so if we uncheck
this you can see we're not going to take
a look at secondary indexes but the
thing that's important is here we can
change to read and write capacity units
so if we set it both to one we'll get an
estimated cost of just 59 cents or
months there conversely if we push this
way up push it up to a thousand then you
see it's five hundred and eighty dollars
a month so it's fully scaleable and you
just sort of pay for what you need so
let's just set this to 1 and 1 so this
is just a demonstration and will click
on create table ok so table is being
created okay so our table has been
created so here we can see the details
of it and it's creation date so what we
now need to do is we can add items to
our table so we click on the items tab
ok and we need to create an item so you
see this is now this should look
familiar to you because we're basically
doing JSON code which is the same as for
the policies in the i''m lesson so we
get to stick in a last name so it's
putting those put me in to a stick
Weaver and then we can add more values
to append this append a string and we'll
put a first-name and we'll put my name
in
and we could put more information if you
wanted but we're just going to leave it
as that so we click on save and there we
are so now I'm in there so I'll click on
create item and let's add a new user in
there so call the last name Smith let's
add another string so I have a new field
called first name and we'll call this
person Wendy and we'll add another row
let's put a string in there and we'll
call this position so this shows what
you can do with no SQL you can basically
just keep changing things in each row
can be different so we've added to the
position of manager and we'll click Save
so now we can see that it's different so
you can do whatever you want basically
you can add as much or as little
information to each row as you wanted
now you can also do a search so if we
wanted to add a filter we could say
search for last name of a string that
equals and there we are so we have
Weaver mark and just to clear that we
just remove that and click on start
search again so it gives you a very
basic overview of what you can do with
no SQL there's an unstructured data and
you can add as much or as little as you
want some other things to look at the
metrics tab here you can see your read
and write capacity what's actually
happening so you can see whether you're
paying too much or if you need to be
paying too much more as the allowance
alarms that we talked about so they were
set up for us some basic alarms if the
threshold goes over point zero eight
reads or writes for a 12 minute period
we'll get notified and here's the
capacity so this is the thing that
you'll see in the exam is that dynamodb
you can just change your capacity and as
and when you want on the fly so our
tables up and running but we could just
say we're on five read capacity units
and five write Krusty units click Save
and we're done it's off and running
straight away and if you knew how much
you wanted and you had a table that you
were going to be using for a lot for
long period like a couple of years you
can click on reserve capacity on the
left hand side and you can purchase
reserve capacity
and you'll get some significant
discounts by doing that so if you know
you have a table that's going to have
some heavy roots and rights going
forward you would purchase reserve
capacity okay so it's a very basic
overview of DynamoDB you just need to
remember that it's instantly scalable
and it's a no SQL database hey once
become an expert in cloud computing then
subscribe to simpler Channel and click
here to watch more such videos turn it
up and get certified in cloud computing
click here